I'll comment this video playing rock 700
chess from the US and really now I need
to I'm down on waiting areas here that
really require me to play stuff that I
dunno not experiment I need some points
okay doing form the Samish yeah this is
some unknown setup that is very good for
the problems for blankets that he has a
hard time to prevent white playing afore
now he has even put the night on d7 so
that after c5 in 96 that is the other
set up that he doesn't even have any
count to play against you for now
playing it playing it slowly but I think
I have some time to prepare stuff before
next I hope
now he probably should play 96 96 so
that after before he maybe has neither
form you know like to prevent that now I
can wear for so before some a threat
yeah he's protecting the square but the
night-night shouldn't be bad down okay
if I go if for now takes takes he can
probably take take on when he form does
not look it does not look great but
maybe he can okay the six there was a
week as a weak spot what about Queen
beef form just trying to put a piece on
d6 in 96 I don't need to play a form I
mean it's the the move I I'd love to
play but I have other ideas maybe look
c6 or something I don't know
Rupert e8 look II D 8 I can can i play
before now I really need to play this if
I can before text eggs yeah
it's a really awful pin but okay let's
strengthen the position even more I'm
not in a hurry
we know the b-pawn this week and I can
also think of playing Bishop III Bishop
III maybe rook c8 coming yeah I cannot
go Bishop b5 because of the night the
slide is hanging but wait wait wait wait
for now okay but he can take this the
the queenís and then in a sort of
opposition here
I think I should forget one blue pail
rooks off
that's a we have moved I can't even play
you for now Knight f4 I have no idea I
have 90 70 okay okay come on this is
really a dream position losing that one
I really need to need to take a longer
break from blitz chest
let's see but I managed to lose quite a
couple of nice positions recently so
cannot be sure at all five I can I can
even take here but Queen takes it's not
it's not 100% clear okay come on yet
these five must be good
yeah 96 is still coming okay I cannot
take now of course probably here at the
end I always have Knight to d6 whatever
is doing 96 is coming yeah maybe if he
goes 98 I'm not playing 96 but then I
still have a nice night on a 5 maybe
Bishop takes actually to avoid the trade
yeah let's do that the night on f5 is
covering diff defaults well for
everything else fails ok 96 no oh wait
wait for just a moment maybe I can
improve more on the night here this is
unstable
yeah this belongs on g6 whatever Bishop
f5 yeah it's a bit afraid about 92
business but I don't think it's really
working
Queen age six maybe okay okay
me too I need to give you a chance piece
maybe it could have taken on d7 as well
I'm taking b6 maybe they're supposed to
use a stack actually I want to trap the
knight now it doesn't have many squares
black resigned
thank God the win I needed this badly
just win whatever win just one yeah yeah
this was a very nice position out of the
out of the opening where black ass is
struggling and yeah I even I think yep
here you fall is more powerful actually
yeah I am
this is this is quite nice check then
grabbing the knight is very good for
white okay but I just I just tried to to
win without any big complications and
this was I think it was okay yeah this
this was working I had the suspicion but
I didn't see a win after that now care I
can just take Orbeez
okay yeah but this should keep on should
keep an advantage right yeah and it
keeps an advantage he should take the
the knight the bishop though this is
such a strong piece this was this was
not so good so now with Bishop f5 I'm
I'm in good shape he can play this is
cool he can play queen h6 and and this
is playable even in this game I'm really
allowing so much stuff unbelievable
Queen e3 is much better and this wins
actually you know this is this is losing
but this is okay computer actually says
it's drawing immediately yeah probably
because this is the threat yeah and if I
take what does he doing
I'm even losing I don't believe it this
is what I had planned I thought that
here yeah okay I thought here I have
Queen c2 because I forgot that the
bishop is not on f5 anymore yeah and
then I'm in trouble that's clear this is
a big threat Queen e3 Queen B - yes so I
could have easily lost this game as well
unbelievable
check yeah now everything's in order
again winning the the piece yeah very
shaky play at the moment but at least I
won the game thanks for watching